joining me now is n gangri former
speaker of the house and Fox News
contributor um new you know it it's it's
almost getting um getting tiresome to
say this but Trump was right again he
said this EV Obsession was going to
drive the Auto industry into the dirt
and we're already beginning to see
that well look I mean the problem for
Biden and for his whole reelection
effort is reality that every time you
turn around leftwing policies fail and
this is a perfect example uh they have
this crazy idea you can somehow Force
the American people to buy a vehicle
they don't want using technology they
don't trust in systems that in fact at
times don't work for some people
electric vehicles may be great for most
people they're not and I think what
you've had is the big people at the very
top of these giant corporations have
been coerced by the big government to
decide to impose on the American people
things they just don't want and the
American people's reaction is to say no
that's why you I I hear auto dealer
after auto dealer talking about how many
cars they have sitting on their lot that
are electric that they literally can't
move because people don't want to buy
them well n Nate silver um posted on X
this week that um real wages are up
since 2019 he's laughing at that because
that's what the uh Biden people people
are saying which he he's essentially
making the argument which is the correct
one that there has been zero real wage
growth for the median worker Over a
four-year period and and we see from the
time that Biden actually was sworn into
office to today the standard of living
for most Americans is down so that's not
a that's not a winning economy that's a
terrible economy and now union workers
union workers shifting Republican how
big is that
look I I used to when I was running for
office I used to follow what I called
the Walmart test and that is you go
stand outside of a Walmart and you ask
people what they're really thinking what
they're really doing and I guarantee you
that the average person who is shopping
at Walmart today does not believe that
Biden has been good for their pocketbook
does not believe that prices have gone
down does not believe uh that they
should be grateful for the current
economy and all the polling data
reinforces that but it's not complicated
go to your grocery store look at the
price of milk or or eggs or chickens uh
or bread U go to your gas station yes
it's down a little bit from its peak but
it's way above where it was under Donald
Trump and I think what you're going to
find is that on topic after topic people
are going to say to you this is not
working and that's the number one
problem for Biden in the real world with
real people it just ain't working n
great to see you tonight thanks so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling annalysis you will not get it
anywhere
else